Welcome back to "Drew's News".
Let me just say everyone in our audience looks so stylish.
I really, I mean, gosh, you look good.
Yeah.
Meow.
I want your suit, I'm looking at you, cute.
Everyone came to show up and I'm seeing...
I'm picking up what you're putting down.
Next up, we love following a great romance.
And right now we are so
on the Pete Davidson and Kim Kardashian love train.
Fascinated.
Wait until you hear this one.
Okay, remember when it all started,
and Kim was on SNL and she played...
Oh, Ross.
Oh, hello.
Oh oh.
Okay.
He was Aladdin, and she was Jasmine,
and we know which one you'd pick,
and they rode that cute magic carpet together.
And they had that kiss that I think we all
kind of were like, whoa about,
'cause we all kind of went, oh my God,
they would be so amazing together.
Okay, well now "People" reports that for Valentine's day
Pete gave Kim both of their costumes, the lamp and the rug
so that they can remember that magic moment forever.
Just like, you know, what a nice thing to do for someone.
No, it's so cute to go back, I just watched it
to see how like they started, you know?
And then right after that she showed him a whole new world,
and then it all went from there.(chuckles)
You know what I mean?
And you were drooling over Aladdin.
Yes.
Yes, we know.
Well Rossi, tell me about this next story
'cause it's a trend.
Yeah, well you know we love the latest and greatest trends
here and it's time for a "Drew's Review."
(audience cheering)
Everything we review comes from you, our viewers,
and today's suggestion comes from Julia Jones.
Hi Julia.
Thanks for this one.
Alright, today we're gonna try
the fastest growing sport in America.
It's something called Pickleball.
You heard of that?
Has anyone heard Pickleball?
Pickleball, you guys know it?
What is it about Pickleball,
because people are going bananas.
They're losing their minds.
Yeah, they are relishing every second of Pickleball.
Oh.
Yeah, stop it.
So stupid, so stupid.
No, but it's a big dill.
Apparently, apparently Pickleball is like ping pong
and tennis and badminton all hooked up and had a baby, okay,
and they called it Pickleball.
So it's easy to set up.
It takes less space than a tennis court,
and it's easy on the old body.
And guess what Drew?
We're gonna Pickleball it right now.
Come with me.
Really?
Yeah, come on.
(audience cheering)
I'll do red.
This one, got a headband, give me your ball.
Hold my ball, thank you.
Put a headband on, that's cute.
We got our headband, here's your paddle.
Come over here.
Am I going?
Yeah, right over here.
(audience cheering)
So, here's how it works.
The basic rules are simple.
The game goes to 11 points,
and you're allowed one bounce on each side.
So you get a point only if you've served.
Are you ready Drew?
Oh, okay.
Easy right, here.
First time playing.
Oh shoot.
Oh no, hold on.
Let me be specific.
Wow, I suck at this game.
You're supposed to hit it back to me okay?
Three, two, okay, there you go.
Oh, good Drew, good.
Oh good.
(audience cheering)
Listen, I can build you a brand, I'm not a good athlete.
(audience laughing)
(Drew and Ross laughing)
(audience clapping)
Don't clap, don't clap for her.
Well, I mean, you know what, here?
Just.
What?
There you go.
Oh sir, come, will you come Pickleball with me?
Come on, come on, come on.
(audience cheering)
Come on sir.
There you go.
(audience laughing)
Alright, come on, there you go, good.
Oh yes, oh yes, okay.
Okay, whoa, hey.
Still, so much better.
Thank you.
Well done.
Thank you so much, thank you.
Now that's how you play it, thank you.
(upbeat music)